أردنا أن نرى
كيف تبدو الحياة تحت حكم طالبان ،
سافرنا إلى أفغانستان وتمكنا
من قضاء يومين
في إقليم طالبان
[موسيقى] ،
غالبًا ما نفعل ذلك عندما
نعمل معًا عندما نبدأ
بخير ، ما هو الحلم
وبعد ذلك  دعنا نقسمها ونحاول
القيام بذلك ،
كانت هذه مهمة حيث قالوا ،
اسمع ، لقد قررنا
السماح لك في هذه المجالات
وسنجيب على أسئلتك ،
فنحن لا
نحبك هنا
ولكننا ندرك ذلك  في هذه
اللحظة من المناسب سياسياً
أن نفعل هذا
أه للقيام بذلك ، من الواضح أننا كنا نرتدي
حجاب الوجه الكامل ، والنقاب
من ناحية يسمح لي بأن أكون
غير مرئي
من ناحية أخرى ، فهو يمنع الطريقة
التي تتفاعل بها مع الأشخاص الذين
هم  لا تريدنا أن
نخرج لأنني امرأة ولم نكن
نرتديه فقط لأسباب أمنية
كانت بالطبع جزءًا منه ولكننا كنا
نرتديه لأننا كنا مطالبين
بارتدائه وكان هذا شيئًا لنا
أراد المضيف بشدة القيام به  تأكد من أننا
فهمنا
أننا عملنا عن كثب مع مخرج أفغاني
في نجيب الله قريشي ،
لقد كان حقًا الشخص الذي يتمتع بالسمعة الممتازة
التي سمحت له بإحضار نفسي
وسلمى
إلى أراضي طالبان ،
وأعتقد بشكل أساسي أن هذه القصة
لا يمكن أن يقوم
بها رجل لا  قد يسأل المرء عن اسمك لن
يسأل أحد حقًا من أين أنت
لأنك كنت
امرأة مع رجل أفغاني وسيكون من
الوقاحة
إلى حد ما أن يسأل الرجل الأفغاني
أسئلة شخصية حول هويتك أو
من أين كنت.
على الرغم من أن النساء كن
في أماكن هؤلاء النساء
وعليك أن تعلم أن المسافة
التي يجب على الرجال أن يخلقوها ،
فقد كانوا مهذبين للغاية
وأرادوا الاستمرار في التحدث إلينا ،
فقد جلبوا لنا أفضل طعام
لديهم أفضل ما يراهنون عليهم.  لو
كان من اللطيف حقًا رؤية ذلك
الجزء العائلي جدًا من أفغانستان